the interception of ryanair flight 4978
is now a full-blown international
diplomatic crisis
belarus state media says president
lukashenko personally ordered a military
jet
to escort the passenger plane away from
its scheduled route
and diverted to minsk it's an act which
european leaders have branded
state-sponsored piracy
and there is now intense pressure for a
stern response
flight tracker sites showed the ryanair
flight from athens to vilnius
changed course just two minutes from the
lithuanian border
belarus air traffic control had flagged
a supposed bomb alert to the aircraft
then scrambled a fighter jet to make
doubly sure
the plane came to minsk the target of
the extraordinary intervention was this
man
roman protesovic an opposition
journalist and blogger
who fled belarus after president
lukashenko claimed victory in last
august disputed election
fellow passengers on the plane say he
reacted to the interception
first with disbelief and then
resignation one minute he was a
like trying to negotiate with a steward
but nothing to do but after that
i didn't find him a scared or hungry or
something like that
the incident will dominate the summit of
european leaders gathering in brussels
later on monday
nato will consider its response when it
meets on tuesday
there are demands for yet more sanctions
against lukashenko and his closest
officials
as well as calls to suspend all transit
from belarus into the eu
lukashenko is sort of testing the
uh the tolerance of the eu showing
uh that uh he can get along with even at
the background of a strange relations
with the west
and being under sanctions and
condemnation and his legitimacy is not
recognized by eu
leadership he can still make this
powerful moves
prosecute his opponents even those who
managed to
escape belarus alexander lukashenko has
been belarus president since 1994
a leader described in some quarters as
europe's last dictator
and a man who has a record of harshly
repressing dissent but he is strongly
supported
by his ally russia he is uh
playing his trump card saying that we
together with russia against the west
against hypocrisy and imperialism
and that's what he's playing and uh he
is playing this card in order to ensure
uh russian support russian money and
russian influence
in light of very mild and very uh
appeasing sanctions of european union
america
it's now known that 125 passengers
departed from athens and only 121
arrived in vilnius lending credence to
reports that protacovich had been
followed onto the plane by belarus
intelligence agents
the midair interception is looking less
and less like an opportunistic act
and more like a planned and coordinated
snatch operation
and the dilemma for the west is how to
respond to that
paul brennan al jazeera